July is upon us so now it's time for
some new dr. Sadler channel updates I'm
going to tell you about what went on
during June quite a busy month what
we've got coming up in July again quite
a busy month before I do that I've
started this new practice of talking
about three major things that I want to
bring your attention to and the three
major things this month are indeed quite
major so the first of these is that we
are actually relocating to the Midwest
this fall specifically to Wisconsin
which is where I and my wife are both
from we actually went to high school
together and we're going to be doing it
in a set of staged moves because we have
quite a lot of stuff much of witches
books that's going to have to make it to
to our new abode and that's going to
entail quite a lot of major changes it
shouldn't actually produce any
significant changes as far as the
YouTube channel goes and really anything
that I've got that's that's
internet-based that's portable I'm going
to be doing more or less the same sort
of stuff I'm going to continue at the
half hour Hagel core concept videos
teaching online all that sort of stuff
can be done from anywhere what it's
going to mean some some real changes as
far as where I'm doing talks I have to
create a whole new network of local talk
centers fortunately I'm coming back to a
place that I came from originally so
that that should be pretty easy by the
way if you're in Wisconsin specifically
in southeastern Wisconsin and you're
interested in having me come and give a
talk get in contact with me Greg at
reason I oh and we'll we'll work out
some details but that's some some really
significant news we're also going to be
stepping up once we're on the ground and
well established we're gonna be stepping
up some of the activities that we
started doing here in the Hudson Valley
and we'll be doing in much more
systematic and larger ways in
southeastern Wisconsin also the
Chicagoland area the second thing that
I'd like to bring to your attention is
that I've got a conference coming up in
Boston at the end of july it's about
st. Anselm's somebody who I do a lot of
work on so Boston is actually a fairly
small big city and if any of you you
know viewers fans subscribers out there
would like to meet up I will be I think
it's at boston college I was hosting it
I will be there I'll be giving a talk on
the Wednesday of the conference which
I'll get to a little bit later on and
I'm going to be in the area so if you'd
like to meet up for a couple minutes or
you know for an hour or have a have a
beer or you know who knows what else get
in contact with me again Greg at reason
I oh and we'll see what we can do i'll
be there from the monday through the
thursday of the conference the other
thing I've got coming up is a play-doh
class specifically on Plato's symposium
it's a four-week global Center for
Advanced Studies online class that i'll
be teaching and it's going to start
enrolling in about a week or so i'll be
putting out a video is an advertisement
for that and will will actually get the
class started with the first video
session around the beginning of august
so that's coming up if you've always
wanted to study Plato's symposium with
somebody who has been reading it and
rereading it for years and years and
years we actually did a course
specifically on it just on the symposium
for an entire semester in Greek well I'm
your guy the price is right too it's
it's a hundred and fifty dollars for a
one credit course but there's also the
possibility of auditing it for a lower
cost than that but I'll you'll see stuff
about that in the video when I put it
out so let's talk about June what went
on during the month of june i began the
month by going up to st. Anselm College
where I did a summer research residency
I was hosted by the Institute for st.
Anselm studies which is really great on
their part they they put me up and they
they gave me a per diem for for food and
travel expenses and I worked on
materials in the scene handsome
action the Aurora collection in the
geisel library they have a whole room
you can you can see videos about this
i'll hit on that in just a moment and i
did work for the the institute and for
the library with some other
dissertations trying to produce
abstracts and keywords for them and i
also did a lot of work my own projects
dealing with an some including getting
this paper right for the conference that
i've got in july that ended with the
meta physics colloquium which is always
a great thing that's one of the things
that i may not be able to get to go to
regularly once we move but it's been
great to be able to go to it while I've
lived in this area with Santa and psalms
is only four hours away the meta physics
colloquium is a two-day conference that
is put on by the Institute for st.
Anselm studies and it always deals with
some issue or issues in metaphysics this
time it had to do with beauty and the
nature of beauty and artistic production
and and how all those sort of things fit
in and it brings together some of the
big heavy hitters in in philosophy from
the area also a lot of people from st.
Anselm's college some of whom are also
in that class of heavy hitters it's a
great time for me because i get to see
old friends and talk about really cool
stuff that I'm particularly interested
in so that was great at the end of the
month of june we had the Aquinas
leadership congress and i presented a
paper on well i presented points from my
paper on Thomas Aquinas on anger and how
that has to do with organizations and
leadership as it turned out I presented
for a lot longer than I was supposed to
in part because the other panelist for
my session wasn't there I've got a sound
recording of that which I'll release as
a podcast before too long they also got
video of it but unfortunately they were
testing out a new mic and the sound cut
out like five minutes into it they were
live streaming the event so that will
i'll see if i can get my hands on it if
i can i'll upload it my channel one side
I inserted the sound file but it was a
great discussion the conference itself
was was wonderful some old friends a lot
of new friends and colleagues it was
relatively small so I could go to all of
the sessions until I needed to leave on
Saturday to get back here to the Hudson
Valley one of the things that was really
remarkable about it was it seemed like
half the people there had either
purchased copies of or had read my book
which is you know fairly rare it's not a
book that I'm talking about his reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
Christian philosophy debates in France
it is his translations preceded by a
hundred page historical and thematic
introduction and ended by a something
like a 20-page chronological
bibliography so you know scholarly tool
not the sort of thing that you pick up
for a beach time reading or or you know
anything like that and I would say there
were more people there at this
conference who came up to me and talk to
me about my book then I have run into
anywhere else since the book was
published so that was that was you know
quite cool they were they were all very
happy with it there's a lot of great
things that come out of that including
some talk invitations and some
collaboration invitations June has also
seen a lot of work with the global
Center for Advanced Studies as they gear
up for their their conference this this
July about democracy held the in Greece
where things are really coming to a crux
I've been I've been occupied much more
with trying to build the Institute of
humanities and Social Sciences working
on the certificate program getting
classes lined up you know meeting with
the other directors and the board trying
to work out some of the nuts and bolts
of the infrastructure of the institution
so that's that's been the focus for me
I've also done a lot of academic writing
I haven't done much blogging this month
because I've been more focused on doing
academic writing I did give one talk at
the library in the understanding anger
series this time it was on
epicurean specifically Epicurus some
discussion in Cicero Lucretius and fill
it a MOS and and their views on anger it
was very well received and it actually
started getting some traction among
epicureans on the internet so that
that's pretty cool to continuing to
teach my marist ethics class the
students in that class are doing quite
well there's a few that are kind of kind
of marginal you know a few cases of
plagiarizing here and there a couple
students who are giving me the same old
song and dance about oh I didn't know
the class started at this time but for
the most part the students are really
putting forth some great effort so I'm
happy with that what else June we did
some video work I was only able to
produce for half hour hagel videos in
part because we had some lighting
problems near the end of the month which
which you know put a crimp into video
production of the up in front of the
chalkboard part but I did get four of
them out this month so that's great
people are supporting me still on
Patrian very gratified to have that I
also did a Q&A session for my patreon
patrons I started releasing Epicurus
core concept videos that I produced for
my ethics class that was one of the gaps
in the available video materials I
released a few critical thinking videos
not as many as i would have liked in the
fallacy series i need to do more of
those but one of the things that was
really cool is i did video blogging of
my trip up to st. Anselm's and the
research work that I was doing there
there's four videos that give you kind
of a an inside look at what the life of
scholarship is like you know day by day
by day talking about the work that I was
doing of course I also recorded the
epicurus and anger talk so you can see
that if you're interested in that sort
of thing so that's June now let's talk
about the month of July and what we've
got coming up this month so I got three
main events going on the first one is
coming up next week it is the hagel
global
for Advanced Studies summer reading
group which is actually a closed group
on Facebook but if you email the group
leader or organizer skipper Boatwright
he'll let you write in and they've been
reading the phenomenology so I'm going
to help them out with that I said that I
would I would tackle sections that other
people weren't quite so interested in
discussing so this coming week I am
going to be talking about the second
half of the self-consciousness section
the first half is the sexy master-slave
dialectic that everybody always wants to
talk about and you know everybody knows
about the second half is actually more
important the second half deals with
stoicism skepticism and what Hagel calls
the unhappy consciousness and it's
focused on this can ongoing development
of freedom and the the importance of
what he calls recognition so i'm gonna
i'm going to lead a session on that
we're all be doing quite a bit of
lecturing but a lot of Q&A I suppose as
well in some discussion it's either
going to be hosted on a google hangout
or in a big blue button session I'll put
more information about that as it
becomes available I've already created
events for it and Facebook and Google+
so just you know stay tuned to that if
you're in the Hudson Valley and you're
looking for some interesting discussion
in the understanding anger series on
July eighteenth 1030am I've got Plutarch
on anger Plutarch actually wrote one
book specifically on anger and he
discusses it in other places as well
Plutarch was a what we call a middle
playtest which means that in effect he
was play tennis but also rather eclectic
he would draw up on the Stoics on the
the Aristotelian to some degree didn't
like the epicureans but you know most
people were really that big on them but
we're going to be looking at that
towards the end like I mentioned I've
got this handsome conference I am going
to be presenting july twenty ninth at
two-thirty p.m. and my talk is
specifically on an Psalms prayers and
meditations and on the inch
play between divine justice and divine
mercy in those so those are the events
that we've got coming up I'm going to
try to do some blogging this month in
heavy metal philosopher by the way at
that conference recognizes the heavy
metal philosopher by somebody who writes
for Prague are key of all things not
exactly what you'd expected a Thomas
Aquinas conference but you know pretty
eclectic folk i'm going to write for our
exes dunno antique a my main blog needed
to do that for a while without trying to
do some entries in the half hour Hagel
blog as well I probably won't be writing
and Sadler's existentialism updates for
virtue ethics digest this month but I'm
hoping to do that later on got some
academic writing to do you know get a
lot of work underway some good inertia
moving forward it's not inertia that's
impetus right and what what am I going
to be doing as far as videos so this is
a going to be a good month hopefully for
that I've got a number of Epicurus core
concept videos that i'll be releasing
over the course of the month more half
hour Hagel videos or critical thinking
videos all the Plutarch out anger talk
and I have an interview video with
people important to the history of the
Institute for st. Anselm studies that
I'm putting together that you'll see
later this month as well so have a good
Independence Day weekend have a good
month and tune into some of these things
and if you're in the area come to some
of the talks